I have had my military and our team look
at a wide range of options as the Obama
administration beats the drum for yet
another military engagement here are
three reasons we shouldn't go to war
with Syria nothing today is more serious
and nothing is receiving more serious
scrutiny u.s. foreign policy especially
military action should proceed from
clear and compelling national interests
but neither the president nor anyone in
his administration has clarified what
America's security stake is in Syria's
Civil War humanitarian interventions are
notoriously ineffective in practice if
the president really wants to reduce the
violence that's already claimed over a
hundred thousand lives lobbing cruise
missiles are god forbid putting boots on
the ground is no way to accomplish that
nothing today is more serious and
nothing is receiving more serious
scrutiny President Obama has said that
chemical weapons are a redline that no
country should be allowed to cross but
even assuming such weapons were used by
the murderous Assad regime the case for
treating poison gas is qualitatively
different than far more deadly
conventional weapons is hardly clear why
should weapons that have been most
killed a tiny fraction of people in a
war via trigger for actions nothing
today is more serious and nothing is
receiving more serious scrutiny Obama
hasn't just fail to articulate a cause
for action he hasn't even bothered to
explain what might constitute victory in
Syria the inherent risks are compounded
massively by regional and global
politics involving Iran Jordan Russia
Israel and European countries the u.s.
doesn't even have a clear sense of who
the Syrian rebels are and what their
agenda is for God's sake if the past
dozen years have taught us anything
about foreign policy it's the military
intervention shouldn't be done in a
half-ass fashion without clear and
widely shared goals if the Obama
administration can't be bothered to
articulate why we should fight who were
helping and how we would know that we
succeeded
it's got no business getting us involved
in Syria
for reason TV I'm Nicolas
[Music]